on a l'impression d'un calme précaire il
ya de l'appréhension sans véritablement
panique vous savez que habituellement le
jour de l'indépendance de l'ogaden lieu
à une grande parade militaire d'ailleurs
celle de l'an dernier avait été
particulièrement remarquée avec la
participation des britanniques et des
américains mais cette année les
autorités ont interdit toute
manifestation et tout rassemblement
public en lieu et place de cette parade
militaire vous voyez peut-être dernière
mois ses chars russes qui ont été
détruits pendant pendant ces six
derniers mois et qui sont exposés au
public certaines familles viennent aussi
à photographier
photographier devant on l'a entendu les
autorités ukrainiennes craignent une
attaque russe particulièrement répugnant
d'après le président zelensky et
pourtant ici on a l'impression que on a
un retour à la normalité avec des
restaurants qui sont ouverts le trafic
qui a repris et pourtant des checkpoints
à certains carrefours et puis aussi
régulièrement les sirènes anti aérienne
montre que le danger est encore proche
et ce qui est intéressant c'est que
plusieurs familles sont revenus pendant
l'été pour se retrouver ici mais
beaucoup de femmes avec leurs enfants
ont décidé de repartir parce que parce
que la sécurité n'était pas encore
établie